Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P, here is a caller. So deranged
and incoherent, I don't know if they're under the
influence of drugs or alcohol in this phone call.
It is. It is. Troy, you are under a fake
name and he seems furious that I think.
Well, let me just play it. It's about me. I
don't even know what he thinks. It's something
related to what I said about tipping.
Speaker 3: Hey, David Packman. David
Brooks. And. Yeah. Hey, you're a hypocrite,
Pacman. You made a video about not wanting
the tip when you go out to a restaurant.
Speaker 1: Well, remember, it's not about not
wanting to tip. I tip. Well, everywhere I go,
it's about I don't like tipping culture and I
would like to restructure it so that tips aren't
expected and people are paid a living wage.
Speaker 3: Apparently, it sounds like you go
out to eat a lot. I guess the
best fine dining restaurants.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, if I want to
go out to eat, I'll go out to eat. Troy,
it has. It's none of your business.
Speaker 3: Oh, no. Are you a trust fund
kid or a hedge fund fan?
Speaker 1: I am
neither. I am a self-made man. And.
Speaker 3: But the question is, Mr. Packer.
Well, the point I want to bring off
is you're always doing anti-Trump
videos, and then you do a video on the
service industry and the restaurants.
And how workers should not rely on tips. They
should have wages. Yeah, living wages, I believe
you say. And. Well, that's what Trump was trying
to do. He was trying to bring back good jobs that
the Democrats sent overseas to China. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So listen, Trump didn't have any
idea how to do that. Many of those jobs simply
no longer exist, and it has nothing to do with
tipping culture. I'm afraid to break it to you.
Speaker 3: At one time you didn't have so many
of these restaurants in this country. There
are way too many restaurants, and most of
them are foreign owned. Globalists who play money
grand games, they shuffle money laundering, and
most of these restaurants should not exist
and only exist because of globalization.
Speaker 1: All right. This is very crazy,
I guess, Troy. What? I guess he only has so-called
American food. I don't know. It's a very,
very strange message. But listen, I
for for as long as restaurant workers
depend on tips, I'm going to tip. My point is,
I would like a different structure where we have
prices. The prices include all fees, and then the
employees are paid a living wage. That's what I
would like to see. We're going to talk about
Deepfake technology on the bonus show today and
the role that it might play in the 2024 election.
We are also going to talk about Air New Zealand.
The airline starting to weigh passengers before
they board international flights and the impact
that this is having. And North Korea's attempt
to launch its first spy satellite has ended in
failure. And it is pretty humiliating. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: I can't say it much better than
that. Thank you, Alex. So I will leave it with
you as please sign up at join Pacman dot com. Get
access to the bonus show. Otherwise we'll
be back tomorrow with a new show. See that?